let's go a little bit more onto the side
of women now
um Rich you talk about having an
abundant mindset okay and could you
firstly dive into a bit about what you
mean by having an abundance mindset and
also the dangers of uh of of having the
opposite of that
yeah I think a lot of guys today have a
scarcity mindset so when it comes to the
notion of something like
entrepreneurship I think it's very sexy
today I think it has been for a while
you know for being honest for decades at
least I mean I was very interested even
in the 90s in it
um but I think a lot of guys are
convinced or they have convinced
themselves whether it's through nurture
or nature that there's just not enough
money out there uh that anybody that's
acquired money is possibly and usually
evil and they're using it for nefarious
purposes that there's not enough uh like
oh we all can't be entrepreneurs because
then who would run you know who would
work in the businesses you know for
example
um there's a lot of ego Investments that
people make into uh beliefs that they
adopt And subscribe to that do not serve
them and it's why they get terrible
results out of life you can take a look
at anybody's results and know and
understand completely what their belief
system looks like it's it's it's a
three-step sequence it's beliefs choices
results your beliefs daily will govern
the choices that you make your choices
will then govern the results that you
get it's a pretty clear and
straightforward path
it's it's a it's a very powerful concept
once you understand it
what about when it comes to women
when it comes to women in what regard
okay let's say for example right you
have an individual and that person is
with a woman and he is scared of leaving
her because he feels that he's not going
to be able to go out there and be able
to get another woman okay as soon as you
develop that mindset you're already
setting yourself up for failure because
you're restricted right yeah yeah they
think that they've that they've done the
best that they can
and nothing better can potentially exist
um that's incredibly arrogant in my eyes
there's there's eight billion people on
the planet half of them are are women so
there's roughly you know four billion
women out there that you have that you
could potentially have an opportunity
with that could be a much better fit
um a lot of guys they develop an
unhealthy attachment to a woman it's I
mean it's a concept that's known as
oneitis and a lot of guys get it you
know they get laser focused on that one
girl and it could be because they don't
have the option to get other girls it
could be because religion or culture you
know convince them of that that you know
she's the one there's this notion of the
soulmate myth that many men believe in I
think it's something that's been sold to
us through Hollywood and media and
Disney and stuff like that all the films
growing up were always like The Prince
and the princess and happily ever after
and you know there's an adversary out
there they have to deal with the whole
you know Joseph Campbell hero's journey
you know that story arc
so it really just boils down to Ego
Investments it's it's stories you know
people tell themselves stories all the
time oh I can't get girls because I'm
not tall enough I can't get girls
because the color of my skin is wrong I
can't get girls because I don't have
hair I can't you know fill in the blank
with whatever it happens to be
um if you believe it then you're right
you know it's it's whatever you believe
that is correct you know whether you're
whether you believe in The Wolf Of
Darkness or the wolf of light the one
that you feed is the one that that wins
I heard a story which I'm gonna I'm
gonna tell you about rich right is that
there was um this was there was a person
who was a an ex-army veteran
um he he I think he had he had to he had
to exit the Army early I can't remember
what the reason was but anyway he would
often he was he was a shorter guy and um
he would go into bars and often get into
fights with people and he'd pick fights
with people just to prove himself and
essentially what happened was in the end
he picked a fight with the wrong guy got
hit with a right hand dropped head hit
the head hit the floor and he's dead and
that just goes to show you them limiting
self-beliefs actually in that situation
it cost him his life that's how serious
it can get but um obviously that's an
extreme story but it's just the point
I'm making is if you when you prescribe
to limiting self-beliefs and don't
believe that you are the man that you
can achieve anything if you put your
mind to it you're gonna hinder yourself
in life right absolutely you know these
limitations that you set on yourself are
Gates and barriers that you see are real
there's a there's a story that this guy
told me once he was uh you know he was
working in Africa for decades and you
know he was telling us that they would
sometimes have baby elephants
um you know whether they were orphaned
or whatever happened but they would have
to raise them and they would often just
chain them with like a light dog chain
when they were babies you know to keep
them from you know maneuvering around
and going off and causing havoc and they
would just stay stay put but they could
also use that exact same light dog chain
a very small one where they were
full-grown adults because they believed
that that same chain would prevent them
from leaving all they would have to do
is just move their leg a little bit and
the thing would completely shatter into
a million pieces because that a
full-grown adult size they've got that
level of strength so it's that so it's
that limiting belief it's that barrier
it's that fence that you put around
yourself that is the reality that you
live by it's it's it's not what's out
there what happens to be real it's the
one that you set for yourself that is
real
it's very interesting Rich you know I
followed some of your work I've listened
to you for a while and something that's
been made abundantly clear to me you
tell me I'm wrong here is that you are
quite interested in the psychology of
the mind and you do look into historical
facts and science quite a bit and the
biology and the and human history am I
correct yeah I I find it interesting
because I mean like theory is one thing
and then you've got studies and and data
and results and historical events that
that start to pile up where you can
start to draw reasonably safe and strong
conclusions where you can then make an
overt statement that you feel
comfortable with I don't say anything
that I don't truly subscribe and or
believe and haven't checked in with
either right so when I State something
as uncomfortable as some people might
find it that's fine maybe this comfort
that you're feeling is something that
you need to look at that's not my
problem don't make your problems my
problems but that's how I view the world
right like that's how I see these
realities when I come across them
okay
true I I agree with you and I think just
following your work I've learned a lot
personally but um Okay so
one thing I want to I want to talk about
here and just like you to comment on the
back of if you could rich as well we
were talking about this abundance
mindset and having when you when you're
thinking about
um you know your partner or the woman
that you're with when you develop this
so-called you know one night is of you
as you put it what used to what you can
start to do is you can develop all
nights for the wrong woman and you can
get yourself and I find a lot of men do
this right is you made the mistake where
you get with a woman and when you're
with that woman she doesn't treat you
right or you know whether that's to your
face or behind your back or whatever
maybe she's not right for you and then
because you've got this one-nighters and
this fear that if I leave this person I
am not going to be able to find anybody
else who matches up and that's what our
human brain does right we develop these
fear mechanisms and it's them fear
mechanisms that stop us from exiting
outside of and it's the same thing that
applies when somebody's working in a job
they may be fearful to leave that job
and you get absolutely encapsulated by
this one relationship and you get stuck
in it and you keep dragging it dragging
it dragging it up until the point where
you physically can't be in in it anymore
because something really bad happens and
you call it the trainer the train wreck
right you call it rich yeah it's a train
wreck for a lot of guys yeah
so yeah I just want you to comment a
little bit about that and you know
obviously I'm sure you've dealt with a
lot of men who have been in these sort
of train wrecks and stuck in the wrong
wrong relationships for too long yeah
it's amazing what men will put up with
isn't it um
so they will look past a lot of
different things
um in my book I've got uh 20 red flags
in the unplugged Alpha and one of the
reasons why I put that in the book is to
help men identify common traits of
problematic women
um these are things that that started to
pop up over and over again because guys
were looking for prescriptions on well
is this a good woman or is this a bad
woman is this a red flag sort of thing
and I started to compile this list of
what I started to call red flags
you'll notice now today red flags is a
very popular catch term out there
because a lot of people have now adopted
these flags that I've talked about
talked about in fact a lot of them make
content on the exact same red flags that
are in my book
um they're things like Daddy Issues
dealing with women that have feminist
ideologies women that are always unhappy
and unlucky a woman that may compete
with you in that relationship she keeps
men around from her past she might be
bad with money she could be violent I
mean I could go right down the list you
guys can get all that from the book in
detail but it if you pay attention to
these things when you're dating right
you know if you're dating women and
you're not in the committed phase she
hasn't said to you where do we stand I
dig your Vibe I I want to claim you sort
of thing
um and and you're very casual about it
then once you identify what red flags
are and you see them in women you'll
never get yourself to the point where
you've actually exposed yourself to
danger or risk or even put your wealth
on the line or if you have children with
her than have to deal with custody
issues later on down the road because
simply paying attention to red flags
solves most of those problems for the
vast majority of men some people get
upset about that and they say it's not
as binary or it's not as black and white
as that and I would argue it pretty much
is you know the ones that are saying
that it's that it's not that simple
usually have the red flags that I'm
talking about or at least a few of them
anyway
I think it's extremely difficult I think
um
you know finding a woman who who who has
the green flags has a minimal amount of
redflies is extremely difficult in
today's day and age would you agree I'd
agree because you know women are overly
entitled today uh they have a enhanced
sense of self-worth because before
social media uh women would get
validation from men that they were
exposed to face to face uh in the
schoolyard and maybe the workplace if
they were entering the workplace through
family events through churches you know
Social Circle stuff like that men would
validate them by expressing interest in
them asking them out wanted to take them
on dates telling them that they love
them so things like that today all a
woman needs even an average woman even a
four or five out of ten can have a
social media falling on Instagram use
the right filters the right angles to
take their photographs write clothing
and they'll get a flurry of likes and
DMS and comments from them telling them
that they praise them for their beauty
and they would swoop in and save them
you know all of these narratives it's
it's it's very very common today so you
have that's why you see these girls
today on these podcasts you know there's
a podcast format that's become quite
popular where they essentially get these
girls from large Urban cities and they
sit them down around a table there's a
few drinks that are passed around to
sort of loosen the barriers and they
start having conversations about what
are you looking for in a man what's a
high value man you know what about
feminism and you notice a common Trend
you know they're essentially using these
women to make an example out of them uh
to basically show guys see this is what
women are made of today but at the same
time you also see the level of uh like
like the overestimation that they have
in their worth like a woman will say
well I've slept with you know 50 guys
but I still believe that I am wife
material and then a man should look past
my past and the choices that I've made
in the past and the 50 men that I've
laid with and commit to me put babies in
in me provide a house for me all of that
sort of stuff so we live in strange
times you know we certainly don't live
in our grandparents times it's been said
that my granddad for example it was it
was simple for him to find a woman
that's two or three times as good as a
woman today for half the work
You Know Rich I'm gonna I'm gonna push
back a little bit there because I
disagree with you a bit I think that you
know I used to think that you know times
and obviously right times have gotten a
lot worse and things have gotten a bit
more crazier now but I believe that I I
was thinking of you know in in my
granddad's day that it was like this and
women were like that I don't actually
believe that's the case I think that if
you went back to them times you'd you
know maybe it'd be a bit more subtle
maybe it would be you know across across
the street but it was looking and giving
a little wave maybe and then it develops
in secret but I I believe that and as I
got older and I started speaking to I
should speak to my father about this
about my granddad and some of the issues
that he faced and some of them stories
that I heard were were unbelievable I
couldn't believe that my granddad
actually faced some of these same issues
that we're facing in the year 2023 it's
insane well women were still hypergamous
back then there's no doubt about that
they would always want the best that
they can get but the difference today is
women have been sold this uh you know
this book of lies toxic feminism is what
I would call it you know they're drunk
on this cool that if a woman needs a man
like a fish needs a bicycle and uh you
know men are incompetent men have been
have been portrayed throughout media
culture advertising Hollywood for
decades now of being bumbling fools you
turn on any television show or or sitcom
even from the 80s or 90s the men were
always portrayed as morons and the women
were portrayed as Heroes that is a stark
difference from the Leave it to Beaver
days for example which were the
television shows that
um my parents and grandparents you know
sort of grew up on even even prior to
that so
I mean the truth of matter is is that
women are women and men are men but at
the end of the day women today are very
very different from the types of women
that our parents dated uh they they have
lower Notch counts back then than what
they do today it's it's pretty common
today especially when women sort of lean
into the toxic feminism narrative and
you can be as promiscuous as men can
without consequence sort of thing and
shame you sort of it still kind of
exists but it's not like it was back in
the day sort of thing women are very
different today
um I'm not taking away the fact that
challenges exist and our parents and
grandparents age the fact of the matter
is that the challenges today are very
different and I think they're harder for
men today it's it's a lot more difficult
for men today to pair bond monogamously
to one chick over a long period of time
because women today are not wired that
way anymore like they were decades ago I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out